- J'avais hâte de parler
au Dre Caroline Quach depuis
ce matin. Bonsoir, Dre Quach.
- Bonsoir, Monsieur Roy.
- J'ai des questions vraiment
très simples pour vous.
On va revenir un peu aux points
fondamentaux concernant
la vaccination parce qu'on
entend parfois qse
et son contraire. Les doubles
vaccinés, Docteure Quach,
dans quelle mesure sont-ils
protégés devant l'Omicron?
Que nous dit la science?
Dre CACH,
microbiologiste-infectiologue
et son contraire. Les doubles
vaccinés, Docteure Quach,
dans quelle mesure sont-ils
protégés devant l'Omicron?
Que nous dit la science?
Dre CAROLINE QUACH,
microbiologiste-infectiologue
- Alors, la science nous dit
que contre l'Omicron, ils sont
peu protégés surtout quand
ils sont rendus à peu près
six mouxième dose.
Donc, il y a une protection
d'à peu près 30 à 40 % contre
les infections qui augmente
à hauteur de 75 % après la dose
de rappel. On est loin du 93 %
qui était la protection
après la dose de rappel pour
le variant Delta, mais quandmême
après deux doses.
- Bon, troisième dose.
Parce que là, on insiste partout
sur cette troisième dose,
le plus vite possible.Est-elle ?
Protège-t-elle, le sait-on,
contre l'Omicron?
- Bien c'est ça, la troisième
dose protège autour de 75 %
contre. Ce que
je vous disais, c'est que cette
troisième dose protégeait à 93 %
contre le variant Delta.
Contre les hospitalisations,
ça semble, la protection
de deux doses semble à peu près
maintenue autour de 70 % alors
qu'on était à peu près à 95 %
contre le varian le varian le v.
Maintenant, on a encore
très peu de données en termes
de protection de cette troisième
dose contre les hospitalisations
mais on s'attend à ce que
ce soit meilleur que contre
les infections, donc au-delà
de 75 %, probablement plutôt
autour de 85-90.
- On nous disait, au Québec
notamment, que la deuxième dose
allaitbonne pour une durée
d'au moins six mois et que, bon,
là, on dit : bon, bien, on va...
on recommande après cinq mois
et il y a des endroits que
encore moins que cinq mois.
Qu'en est-il? À quel moment la
troisième dose devient idéale?
- Bien, en fait, avec l'Omicron,
on a l'impression que
c'est relativement...
On essaie de donner
le plus rapidement possible.
Maintenant, il faut réussir
à prioriser les gens qui vont
avoir  cette dose-là
en premier. Habituellement,
ce qu'on essaie de faire,
c'est toujours de prioriser
les plus vénérables et
c'est pour ça que les plus âgés
sont passés d'abord,
les travailleurs de la santé,
les gens avec des maladies
chroniques, et ensuite,
on continuera à déployer
vers le bas.
- Mais vous êtes d'accord
avec l'insistance qu'on entend
partout? Bon, au Québec,
on dit qu'on ne peut pas aller
plus vite parce qu'il manque
d'employés. Mais vous êtes
d'accord avec donc cette
affirmation que la troisième
dose va vraiment nous protéger
davantage contre l'Omicron?
- La troisième dose va
nous protéger davantage,
mais je pense qu'il ne faut pas
se mettre la tête dans le sable
et on ne peut pas... on ne peut
pas ne pas penser aux mesures
non-pharmacologiques, donc
de distance physique, qu'onavai.
La transmissibilité de ce virus
est tellement grande
qu'on  jamais jamais jamais jams
à vacciner suffisamment de gens
pour faire un mur face
à ce virus-là. Donc, l'idée,
c'est vraiment de limiter
le plus possible le nombre
de contacts à l'intérieur
sans masque pour ralentir
la transmission parce qu'ilsembe
à une vitesse extraordinaire
dans le nez des gens
et donc devient excessivement
contag
- Bon bien, vous m'amenez
à ma dernière question.
Je vais vous la poser
tout de suite et je reviendrai
aux voyages après. Donc, Noël,
rassemblements, est-ce que
vous croyez qu'on doit être
encore plus clair au Québec
notamment et de dire :
ce n'est pas une bonne idée
de se rassembler plus que
5, 10, 15? Où vous en êtes dans
votre réflexion face à Noël?
- Honnêtement, de dire 5, 10
ou 15, là n'est pas la question.
Si on fait cinq personnes
fois six, sur trois jours,
ce n'est pas mieux que de
30 d'un coup. Encore une fois,
l'idée, c'est vraiment
de limiter le plus possible
les contacts. Puis, à l
si on est les mêmes 20 pendant
deux semaines dans un chalet,
pour moi, une fois qu'on sait
qu'on n'est plus
le risque est mitigé. Donc,
cette espèce d'obsession, comme
vous le disiez t
à savoir on peut avoir
exactement combien de personnes
dans la maison à un moment
donné,
c'est un peu artificiel.
Ce qu'on veut, c'est limiter
le plus possible le nombre
de perre,
essayer de limiter nos contacts
avec d'autres avant d'arriver
à ces rassemblements familiaux
ler avecler avecler avecler avec
la maison la plus grande
pour qu'on ait le plus d'espace
possible entre les gens
l de diffusion
et une ventilation, une aération
la meilleure possible.
Mais ce qu'on veut, c'est être
le moins possible à risque
d'arriver à nl
avec un Omicron dans le nez.
- C'est de la musique à
mes oreilles ce que vous dîtes,
Dre Quach. Vous dîtes qu'il faut
arrêter l'obsession, et vraiment
je le dis, je me suis permis
re
avec Sébastien, l'obsession
de 10-12-15. L'idée, comme
vous avez bien expliqué,
ux contacts.
Limiter... C'est comme
les boules de billard
sur une table de billard.
ême groupe
tout le temps, bien, il y a
moins de contacts nouveaux.
Mais si on se promènelein de so,
c'est là le problème!
- Exactement.
- Bon. Voyages, vous avezu Otta,
on nous dit : ce n'est pas
une bonne idée. Vous allez
être pris là-bas.Vous nVous nVos
revenir parce que si vous
attrapez la COVID, je ne sais
pas, au Mexique, peu importe oùc
un test positif, reprendre
l'avion pour revenir au Canada.
Qu'est-ce que vous en pensezyag?
- Bien, c'est vrai. Je pense
que ce qui est compliqué,
c'est de savoir, une fois rendu
à l'étranger,
Est-ce qu'on va pouvoir revenir?
Qu'est-ce qui vont nous demander
comme mesure pour reprendre
l'avion? Encore une fois,
si l'Omicron est partout
au Canada, de limiter l'arrivée
de nouveaux cas d'Omicron,
c'est une mesure qui n'est passe
que c'est vraiment de dire
aux Canadiens que si jamais
ils partent, c'est possible
que ce
revenir.
- Voilà. Dre Quach, très clair.
Merci beaucoup de nous avoir
parlé ce soir.
- Merci. Bonne s